what i learned
is that gender ideology is totally
absolutely
pervasive
um this is not as conservative sometimes
like to reassure themselves
strictly the province of gender studies
professors and weirdos on tick tock
many of whom are gender studies
professors as it happens
the basic tenets of gender ideology
you know that gender is fluid that
people can decide for themselves whether
they're men or women
that transgenderism is a valid and
healthy state of being
which should be encouraged and affirmed
that sex is not binary that there are
dozens if not in infinity of valid
identities outside of man and woman
these beliefs however half-baked and
incoherent they may be
can be found everywhere in the country
stop any average person on the street
i've done it
no matter what they look like or how old
they are
and they are likely to talk about gender
in ways very similar to how a gender
studies professor would talk about it
they may not realize who they're
parroting but they are parrots
nonetheless and they don't even know it
they've adopted these beliefs or
pretended to and we'll return to that in
a minute the pretending part of it
now beyond the average adults walking
down any average sidewalk the most
powerful institutions are fully
enthralled
to this mania
this is particularly the case among the
medical pharmaceutical and psychological
industries and within uh education i
talked to a therapist
who was ready to affirm me as a woman
because i confessed to enjoying scented
candles
in all seriousness
i did also mention in fairness that i've
seen sex in the city one time and so
that's what put me over the edge and she
said
well you know that's a good question
maybe you're a woman
i talked to a pediatrician who refused
to even agree
that only female chickens lay eggs
and she would not agree with that
because she said she doesn't know a
chicken's gender identity
very very real
i talked to a college professor who
called me condescending and rude
because i use the word truth
now these people are not fringe within
the institutions they represent
they are utterly standard commonplace
this is what they're all like and
through these institutions these ideas
are fed to the public they're dumped out
onto the masses like a you know giant uh
sewage pipeline
children of course are most susceptible
as many children in our country today
are indoctrinated into the gender cult
practically from birth
they're put on the the path to identity
crisis and mutilation and
despair
and oftentimes
suicide
before they're even out of diapers
they're exploited indoctrinated lied to
drugged
they are chemically castrated with drugs
that are meant for cancer patients
with drugs that we actually do give to
pedophiles and sex offenders to
chemically castrate them we give those
same drugs to 12 year old boys
now i i talked to a pediatrician as i
mentioned who gives these drugs to kids
and i and i asked her about this and
i said well this same drug lupron that
you give to kids isn't that used to
chemically castrate sex offenders
and she said this interview is over